lui vient d'inscrire son nom au palmarès
des chefs qui innovent avec quelques
jours de retard christophe est a ouvert
aujourd'hui à blois son établissement de
luxe fleurs de loire c'est son nom
comprend un hôtel un spa et deux
restaurants bien sûr un pari sur
l'avenir pour le loir-et-chérien qui a
fermé son restaurant deux étoiles de mon
niveau pour se lancer dans cette
nouvelle aventure samuel colard
la tartelette de tarama de brochets de
loi avec son voile de pomerleau et on
termine sur le quotient de poche et de
bosses premiers services ce midi et
découverte de cette cuisine ouverte sur
la salle dernier cri l'ensemble
fonctionne à l'électrique al'inverse de
l'ambiance dans la brigade tout en
silence et concentration
c'est un rejet concombre sur le tartare
de mairie pour les servir
c'est ce qu'on a à faire 80 personnes
travaillent à fleur de loire entre
l'hôtel et les deux restaurants dont
amour blanc volontairement plus
accessible avec un ticket moyen de 75
euros la carte est créée autour des
poissons avec pleine vue sur la loire à
travers les baies vitrées ou en
extérieur en plus on bénéficie
aujourd'hui d'une terrasse ensoleillée
donc ça pour tous avec avant c'était
parfait il faut dire les choses
on s'est régalé pour christophe et
l'investissement est conséquent 8
millions d'euros l'objectif obtenir une
troisième étoile au guide michelin suis
ultra endettés mais c'est pas grave
parce que quelque part j'ai un outil
comme je voulais le construire ça va
être à nous de le faire évoluer de le
faire avancer ouverture progressive car
les travaux continuent pour le spa et la
piscine une partie de l'été la
boulangerie-pâtisserie doit l'ouvrir
mardi lui juillet